Just such a, it's, it's,
it's recreational. Yeah. There's a,
there's a, I mean it's back to Jack.
I mean it's a lot that has a lot to
do with social media and Twitter in
particular. Yeah. I mean you
have like so, so for instance,
I missed the whole Covington
high school Catholic fiasco,
not on Twitter, basically
was ignoring Twitter. I saw,
I saw it out of the corner
of my eye. Like, man, this is
interesting. This is, yeah,
this is blowing up. But I, I
was so off Twitter that I had,
there was no temptation for
a hot take from me. Right.
And I saw these people just torching
their reputations by taking these like,
like Kathy Griffin basically calling
for the doxing of these kids. You know,
given all that she has suffered from,
from mob behavior online and she's
whipping up her own mob. It was just nuts.
But it's normal.
That's what people do.
It's what the platform
is calling out of people.
But it's also when people have been
shamed and they've done something awful,
then they reinforce their base like that.
Now she's like his so heavily hard left
because the right wing ran after her.
Like anyone on the right
that does anything.
She's calling for her side
to go after this person.
Like reinforcing the cheese,
a part of that tribe that she's a part
of that left wing tribe. Yeah. Yeah.
Well it's, so obviously everyone
has a lot to lose doing this,
especially in a case where
all the facts aren't in.
And if you just waited a beat and even
the New York Times got this wrong,
the New York Times writes an article
about the kids in the Maga hat that they
have to resend.
And the,
so then as the dust is settling
and I see these people,
some people are doubling down, some
people are, are issuing public apologies.
I see somebody who is actually
kind of car, you know,
branded herself as, you know,
one of my enemies for, for
a reason. I can't fathom.
But th this journalist Kara
Swisher, uh, who, um, you know, she,
she works for uh, uh, recode and vox now,
but she's got a big
podcast and she's a bitch.
She actually writes for the New York
Times. Now she's got an opinion piece,
you know, a regular column for the New
York Times. She's a tech journalist. Um,
and I, you know, happen to know she hasn't
liked me because she's tweeted against,
you know, she's said some disparaging
things about me on Twitter and we had a,
you know, an offline conversation
about it. Uh, but I saw her,
she said one of the most but two parative
and you know, fairly crazy things in,
in response to the kids initially.
And then once more information came out,
she walked it back and she basically
apologized, you know, good for on Twitter.
And so, so I said, good for
you Cara. I just wanted to,
to support this norm of acknowledging
that you got something wrong and I wanted
to do it even.
I wanted to actually do it for someone
who I know really doesn't like me. Like,
I mean, that was an added bonus
for me because that, that's,
that's another norm that I,
that I think we should support this like,
like we should, we should play fair even
with our enemies. And I mean, honestly,
I, you know, I try to play fair even
with people who never play with me.
Even someone like, you know, Glenn
Greenwald's Racsana Salon, I mean,
people who have just
lied about me endlessly.
If I get something wrong about them,
I publicly apologize for it. Um,
so I did this,
and this was at the absolute 11th
hour with respect to this, this,
uh, you know, a scandal online.
And when I saw the kind of pain I
was getting just for a con, you know,
s supporting Kara in her walk back of
this thing we had at a moment when it was
obvious she should've walked this
back. I got people saying, you know,
unsubscribing from your
podcast, you are, you know,
now I know you're a fucking racist. You
know, it was just, I'm just sure pain.
And I just thought, wow,
man, that's, you know,
it's like you just touched this thing
at it's very end and you're, you're,
you know, it's, Eh, the slime
it gets on you. Um, so yeah,
it is. It's the medium, you know, we
had no opportunity to do this before.
It is the medium and it's also people
that don't feel like their opinions are
being heard.
Like they want their opinion to be heard
and they want it to be heard right now.
And it might not be a very
well thought out opinion,
but they know that they have the
ability to blare it out and so
they just send it out and that,
that, the ability to do that,
it's just intoxicating for folks
and don't think to reach you.
You talked about this with Jack.
There is out there.
What makes Twitter especially good for
this is that everything has the same
stature. Like your tweets no bigger than
the other tweets that just called you an
asshole.
Yeah,
that's my Kurt Metzger take on it because
Kurt Metzger was a hilarious standup
comedian. He, uh, he'll
write a Facebook blog only.
You only writes on Facebook and he's like,
I like how it's set up. He's like, it's,
there's a big D,
it differentiates between me and these
fucking idiots who are commenting under
there of, although ironically
I hate Facebook. I can't even,
I mean just the graphic
design on Facebook.
I find so offensive that I
can't even look at Facebook.
So I use it as a publishing
channel. But I, you know,
I keep threatening in my own mind to just
delete the account cause I just don't
read the comments three times maybe ever
read him. It's like truth is Christ.
It's like youtube but alive.
I don't know,
it's like youtube but with people
with their real names, right?
It's,
you know,
this is a new world that we're living in
man and everybody's trying to navigate
this thing and figure it out as it goes
along and not everybody is doing it well.
And uh, I think this world is going
to get more and more intrusive.
I think this is just the beginning.
I think we didn't see Twitter coming,
whatever comes after Twitter.
And this is one of the things that I,
before the podcast I wanted to really
talk to jack about to get his take on what
he thinks is next down the line because
there's going to be something that's
more invasive. There's going to be
something that is more, whether it's a,
I think probably something in
the line of augmented reality.
There were probably a decade away from
something that makes this look like books
look like, you know, a, a fucking
cork board at a bookstore. You know,
although strangely we're
live, we're living through
the golden age of audio here.
It's like, like we, we went
full into video and we're
poised to go like, you know,
three d and Vr,
and then all of a sudden audio is king.